[La musique]
madame c'était
pris en charge est toujours gentille vieille dame
quelle est la raison pour laquelle quelqu'un là-bas
vous le faites quelqu'un d'autre évidemment pas
nous ne savons toujours pas
beaucoup d'autres même des années 90 n'est pas le seul
patient d'un certain âge rentre chez lui
[La musique]
oui oui c'était quand nous sommes arrivés
savait qu'il avait 99 ans pour nous disons
c'était un défi est un défi
nous avons gagné nous en avons gagné un
bataille mais nous n'avons certainement pas
gagné la guerre
aujourd'hui est une belle journée parce que
dame rentre à la maison guérie e
nous avons vu aussi que dans des conditions
bon aussi plein d'esprit en a fait
battre est conscient
il se rend compte où il est il dit à
ne pas vouloir aller dans un autre hôpital
mais à la maison alors ça veut dire que
sont des moments pour tous les malades qui
Je suis
mis en quarantaine qui sont fermés aux États-Unis
hôpitaux les mauvais moments et donc les
rentrer à la maison est une chose très, très
très sympa
[La musique]